en este vídeo vamos a presentar dos
términos nuevos que nos van a ayudar a
comprender mejor la relación entre el
seno y el coseno o las diferentes
senoidal es que existen que tienen la
misma frecuencia pero diferente relación
temporal lo que vemos aquí es la gráfica
de una onda coseno y una onda seno el
eje horizontal es teta o el ángulo en
radiales del seno o el cose no puedo
etiquetar esto como pie entre dos igual
a 90 grados pi es igual a 180 grados
esto es igual a 270 grados y estos son
360 grados aquí tenemos dos escalas
equivalentes para el ángulo en este eje
en grados o en radiales una cosa que
notamos es que el seno y el cose no
lucen iguales pero no se superponen si
cambiáramos el eje horizontal al tiempo
podría decir que el coche no alcanza su
pico cuando el tiempo es igual a cero y
el pico de la onda se no se alcanza
cierto tiempo después
el seno está [ __ ] con respecto al
coseno si ve o los picos aquí abajo
vemos la misma relación el pico del seno
que está en color naranja está detrás
del pico del coseno cuando tenemos esta
relación de tiempo entre dos ondas
periódicas decimos que en este caso el
cose no tiene un adelanto con respecto a
la onda seno y la cantidad que avanza es
la diferencia entre estos dos puntos y
podemos decir que el avance es 270 menos
180 en este caso 90 grados por lo que
decimos que el coche no tiene un
adelanto con respecto al seno de 90
grados y podemos tomar el punto de vista
opuesto y medir en donde se encuentra el
seno en relación al coseno y decir que
tiene un retraso por lo que la frase
sería que el seno tiene un retraso con
respecto al coseno de 90 grados esto es
lo que significan los términos adelanto
y retraso y se aplican a esta idea de
retraso
pero solo cuando estas frecuencias son
iguales si las frecuencias son
diferentes la relación entre ambas ondas
va a cambiar constantemente así que
solamente usaremos adelanto y retraso
cuando las ondas involucradas tienen
exactamente la misma frecuencia una cosa
que quiero hacer es poder expresar los
senos y cosenos en términos de ellos
mismos si tengo esta onda seno de color
anaranjado quiero expresar la en
términos de la onda coseno como puedo
hacer esto noten que el valor del seno
aquí seno de 90 grados o seno de pi
medios cuando veo este valor lo que noto
es que tiene el mismo valor que este es
el mismo pico con un valor 1 pero
90 grados adelantado 90 grados antes
porque es una función adelantada esto
sugiere un factor de conversión siempre
que yo elija un valor de la onda seno si
veo hacia atrás 90 grados veré el mismo
valor para la onda coseno por lo que
puedo escribir seno de teta igual al
cose no detecta menos 90 grados si elijo
un valor en la curva seno y retrocedo 90
grados así me encontraré el mismo valor
en la curva coseno estas dos funciones
me darán el mismo valor puedo usar esta
misma identidad al revés si me encuentro
en esta onda coseno en este punto si le
agrego o me espero en el tiempo
90 grados tendría el mismo valor pero
ahora en la curva seno si veo este punto
en la curva coseno y quiero encontrar el
mismo punto en la curva seno
90 grados al argumento de la función
seno me dará este mismo valor esto me
dice que el coche no detecta es igual al
seno detecta más 90 grados con estas
identidades
podemos convertir algo expresado en seno
a algo expresado en coseno y viceversa
ahora quiero mostrarles otras dos
identidades que son bastante útiles aquí
dibuje con línea punteada el negativo de
la curva naranja o el opuesto de la
curva seno que teníamos originalmente
ahora tenemos el caso en donde el cose
no está atrasado con respecto al seno
negativo llega más tarde en el tiempo
por lo que el coche no está atrás del
seno negativo y ahora escribiremos
identidades similares a estas pero en
términos de el seno negativo coseno
detecta es igual a menos seno que es la
línea punteada de teta menos 90 grados
esto significa que si quiero conocer el
valor del coseno lo volteó y puedo decir
que menos seno de teta es igual al
coseno dt está más 90 grados es la misma
identidad pero al revés si quiero
conocer el valor del seno negativo tomo
ese argumento y le sumó 90 grados lo
adelanto 90 grados y calculó el coseno
de esto y así tendré el mismo valor esta
identidad y esta otra son bastante
útiles ya que nos permiten convertir
senos en cosenos y viceversa y la de
aquí abajo nos sirve para mover los
signos negativos a esto se refieren los
términos de adelanto y retraso que son
digamos que apodos de estas relaciones
entre dos formas de onda diferentes que
tienen la misma frecuencia pero
diferente fase diferente tiempo de fase
con esto encontramos estas identidades
que son muy útiles para poder convertir
estas formas de onda
una a otra y viceversa